stegall in dallas casey thank you white
house officials say winter weather has
temporarily delayed shipment of 6
million coronavirus vaccine doses
however president biden says he is
confident his goal of getting 100
million vaccinations
in his first 100 days will be met and he
says there will be enough vaccine for
all americans by the end of july
the president got a firsthand look at
the u.s vaccination effort today during
a visit to a pfizer
manufacturing plant in michigan the trip
comes
as president biden promises to pour
billions of dollars into vaccination
programs
not in america correspondent peter ducey
has details tonight from michigan
on a tour that included freezers set to
70 below zero
in a state-of-the-art assembly line
president biden seemed most
impressed with quality control it takes
more time
to do the check for safety than it does
actually to make the vaccine
that's how fastidious they are and
they're fast this pfizer factory
produces
seven hundred thousand doses of coven 19
vaccine per hour but
snow and cold are complicating things
look what's happening through the
weather now for example it's slowing up
the distribution believes there was a
bigger problem with vaccines though
president trump my predecessors my
mother would say god love them fail to
order enough vaccines
fail to mobilize the effort to
administer the shots
fail to set up vaccine centers that
changed the moment we took office
good morning to washington d.c biden is
up ending president trump's foreign
policy too
i'm sending a clear message to the world
america
is back back to the obama era when it
comes to combating climate change
and as of today the united states is
officially once again a party
to the paris agreement which we helped
put together and diplomacy with tehran
as the administration signals it's
willing to work with europe on a redo
of the iran nuclear deal we're going to
work in close cooperation with our
european
and other partners as we proceed we'll
also work together
to lock down fissile and radiological
material to prevent
terrorist groups from acquiring and
using them he'd like to team up with
europe to take on
china too competition with china is
going to be stiff
that's what i expect and that's what i
welcome
that competition he sees as president
wasn't there when he was a candidate
talking china they're not bad folks
folks but guess what
they're not a they're not competition
for us president biden doesn't want
global competition for the covet 19
vaccine committing 4 billion dollars to
send doses to low and middle income
countries
it's not enough that we find cures for
americans
there needs to be cures that the world
is able to take part of because you
can't build a wall
or fence high enough to keep a pandemic
out
in the united states he sees getting
shots as a patriotic duty
please for yourself your family your
community
this country take the vaccine when it's
your turn and available
he joked it was available to the
traveling press corps today
i don't know if you all got that 351 000
doses in one pound
we have the we have the we have the
needles so come on up
the president joked about handing it out
but that's not how it works and he later
got more serious acknowledging that
there are people in this country
who need the coven 19 vaccine are being
told to go find it on the internet but
either
don't have access or don't know how
brett you know peter president biden's
nominees have for the most part had a
smooth run but
the nominee to run the office of
management and budget seems like
could be in for a bumpy road here
yes brett nera tandon the progressive
think tank head that biden wants to
run the budget office that would then
take control of
a budget that would help the government
combat coven 19
now needs republican help to get
confirmed because even though she
apologized recently for mean tweets in
the past democrat joe manchin was not
impressed
and he said tonight i believe her
overtly partisan statements will have a
toxic
and detrimental impact on the important
working relationship between members of
congress and the next
director of the office of management and
budget for this reason i cannot support
her nomination the white house is not
going to pull it though getting off air
force one a few minutes ago
president biden said he looks forward to
the votes brett
all right peter we'll watch that one
thank you